[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde réformé les institutions
pourquoi faire quoi qu'on pense de la
réforme des retraites est la cristallisé
un malaise social qui paraît durable
l'emploi répétitif du 49-3 auparavant et
pour cette réforme a mis la
représentation parlementaire en
ébullition au malais social s'est ajouté
une crise politique mais pas de crise de
régime parce que la constitution de la
5ème République a prévu de pouvoir
gouverner par temps de crise certes
certains en appel à une sixième
république mais sans qu'on discerne le
contenu de leur revendications
institutionnelles un retour à la
Quatrième République n'apparaît pas plus
convaincant reste la tentation bien
française d'une bougeotte
institutionnelle alors que les
États-Unis n'ont pas changé de
constitution depuis deux siècles et demi
la France en est à sa 15e
institution depuis 1789 et la Cinquième
République initié par la réforme du
général de Gaulle en 1958 a fait l'objet
de 24 remaniements on prête à l'actuel
président Emmanuel Macron la volonté
politique de remanier à son tour la
Constitution dans quelle direction et
pour en faire quoi nous allons voir cela
avec mes invités que je vous présente
Marie-Noëlle linman vous êtes sénatrice
et vous êtes ancienne ministre Dominique
Régnier vous êtes politologue professeur
à Sciences Po et président de fond
d'Apple Olivier passeleck vous êtes
professeur de droit à l'iPad de
l'Université Paris Panthéon Assas et
Dominique Rousseau vous êtes juriste et
professeur de droit constitutionnel
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir cette citation
de Jean-Louis bourlange elle est pleine
d'humour il n'était pas saint de faire
du président à la fin le symbole de
l'État et le chef du gouvernement le roi
d'Angleterre et son premier ministre
alors la question qui se pose et qu'on a
vu au moment de la réforme des retraites
c'est que il y a cette tendance de
verticalité du pouvoir à
occasionner un grand mécontentement et
laisse apparaître le chef de l'État
comme s'il était le seul et vrai
détenteur du pouvoir politique qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez Marie-Noëlle ben
c'est la raison pour lequel je pense
disons que intrinsèquement dès l'origine
la Cinquième République
cristallise une vision du pouvoir qui me
paraît
pas positif pour le pays considérer que
l'élection d'un seul homme avec quand
même l'essentiel des pouvoirs et
d'autant plus avec toute une série de
choses comme le quinquennat et la
version le calendrier qui fait que on a
une confusion entre un président qui
préside et un gouvernement qui gouverne
de fait une majorité je pense que cette
cette image là est très néfaste parce
qu'elle empêche de produire l'idée que
le peuple français c'est dans sa
collectivité dans sa complémentarité
dans la capacité de décision collective
qui doit trouver ses choix ses
orientations ses voies d'avenir on va
décliner vous allez voir les différents
aspects c'est que ça aussi d'autres
impacts dans d'autres domaines l'idée du
chef d'entreprise tout-puissant que les
corps intermédiaires ont pas beaucoup
d'importance que le collectif est
secondaire par rapport à la délégation
de pouvoir un homme je pense que ça nous
affaiblit collectivement dans notre sens
des responsabilités et dans nos
capacités à décider ensemble alors vous
êtes tous d'accord pour dire que cette
verticalité du pouvoir
obéir en quelque sens
la dimension démocratique du pouvoir
grenier je partage assez largement ce
que je viens de dire Madame manolinman
j'avais envie de dire au fond la
verticalité du pouvoir c'est pas fait
pour être exercée en haut si je puis
dire
il y a bien sûr une fonctionnalité à
cette élection du chef de l'État à cette
forme d'autorité elle peut être d'une
grande nécessité
mais ça ça suppose d'en faire un usage
plutôt exceptionnel de grands moments
d'arbitrage et d'orientation du pays et
je vais maintenir là pour pas prendre
trop de temps mais et en revanche et là
je suis encore une fois tout à fait
d'accord est-ce qu'il va être dit
l'organisation du partage dans la
société il est clair de mon point de vue
que les collectivités locales n'ont pas
suffisamment de responsabilité que la
décision publique n'est pas partagée
avec suffisamment de corps
intermédiaires y compris d'ailleurs le
monde associatif et le monde de
l'entreprise il y a tout un système de
coopération je dirais qui est à
l'abandon inhibé pour porterait sans
doute beaucoup au pays bon oui dans
Microsoft
un peu plus nuancé un peu plus nuancé
parce que je pense que ce que vous avez
décrit ou la citation de Jean-Louis
bourlange se réfère davantage à la
pratique politique de la Cinquième
République au texte de la Constitution
de 1958 si on lit le texte de 1958 le
chef de l'État n'est pas Premier
ministre il est chef de l'État et vous
avez le discours de Michel Debré du 27
août 1958 au Conseil d'État qui explique
très bien que le Président de la
République dit il n'a pas de pouvoir de
décision il a un pouvoir de
solliciter d'autres pays mais là vous
êtes dans la Constitution oui mais
est-ce que vous n'avez pas été choqué
que sur la réforme des retraites l'homme
visait n'était que Macron c'est-à-dire
le président de la République et non pas
tout le gouvernement qui est incriminé
par ça mais parce que depuis 1958 et
pour des raisons la fois historiques la
guerre d'Algérie et à la fin de la
guerre d'Algérie la dissolution de 1962
qui donne une majorité au parti
gaulliste il y a eu alors ce que
certains appellent une dérive d'autres
appellent ça une violation du texte même
de la Constitution qui fait que on va y
venir Emmanuel Macron que ça soit
Nicolas Sarkozy que ça soit Giscard
d'Estaing souvenez-vous de Giscard
d'Estaing en 1969 dénonçant l'exercice
solitaire du pouvoir donc si vous
laissez pas une spécificité d'Emmanuel
Macron que toute toute la la grogne la
colère ou les la consultation se pose se
porte sur le prénom République Olivier
passeleck alors c'est justement
là-dessus qu'il faut préciser des choses
la Constitution de la Cinquième
République avait un caractère bâtard ce
mot et de l'ancien président Georges
Pompidou pour exprimer la dimension
hybride de la constitution de 58 qui
rappelons-le dans son article 3 mettez
au même niveau la démocratie
représentative c'est-à-dire les
élections législatives et une forme de
démocratie directe avec le référendum le
déséquilibre aujourd'hui etant puisque
le recours au référendum est quasi
obsolète qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
oui l'article 3 de la Constitution
l'énonce bien la souveraineté nationale
la partie au peuple qu'il exerce par ses
représentants et par le référendum donc
effectivement cette constitution est
fondée sur deux piliers la démocratie
représentative la démocratie directe
mais malheureusement le référendum est
tombé quasi en 18 il y en a eu que 9
depuis 65 ans 4 par le général de Gaulle
ensuite ça a été un peu dévoyé deux
référendums importants qui ont beaucoup
de tenues qui ont donné lieu des débats
de grande qualité sur Maastricht et sur
la Constitution européenne cela dit en
passant qu'on a contourné peu près par
évidemment le vote le vote de d'autres
dispositions mais moi je veux dire juste
très rapidement une une conviction que
j'ai qui est très profonde et c'est que
ce ne sont pas les institutions qu'il
faut remettre en cause mais ceux qui
sont servent et ceux qui s'en servent en
ce moment ils s'en servent mal et je
pense qu'ils ont accru cet exercice
solitaire du pouvoir parce que
finalement le président de la République
aujourd'hui apparaît comme très isolé et
précisément tout donc converge vers lui
il prétendait être Jupiter dieu des
dieux maître de la foudre mais
maintenant c'est le tonnerre qui lui
tombe sur la tête alors justement
précisons à ce sujet la chose
si la pratique référendaire est tombée
ambitieux études à votre avis c'est
parce que les différents présidents de
la République qui n'en n'ont pas fait
usage craignaient d'être désavouée
moi je communique je ferai une
une remarque d'abord pour dire que je
trouve que c'est très convergent à ce
que nous disons même si chacun prend à
le soin de se distinguer un peu en
réalité Cédric convergent je trouve sur
le fond c'est là qu'il y a un problème
d'usage et si on pense à l'usage il faut
l'inscrire dans l'histoire il me semble
alors c'est tout à fait contestable bien
sûr ce que je vais dire mais il me
semble que nous entrons dans une époque
ça fait un moment comme nous y sommes
rentrés maintenant on sait que c'est sûr
ou il va falloir prendre des décisions
beaucoup plus compliqué que celle que
nous prenions jusqu'à présent si je fais
référence à la situation budgétaire au
déficit etc c'est un argument qui peut
être reçu je ne vois pas dans ce
contexte quelle décision pourrait être
prise avec la sentiment du souverain
dans le cadre de référendum les grandes
décisions que nous allons devoir prendre
sont décisions désagréables qui ne
passeront pas si nous les adoptons par
référendum parce que les gens ne
voudront pas et ça n'est pas pour ça que
la décision n'est pas nécessaire ni
qu'elle est mauvaise
au fond le référendum c'était très bien
pour les époques de croissance forte de
démographie très favorable et de
redistribution programmatique quasiment
universel même si on les parties tarde à
se caler sur cette nouvelle agenda
historique et maintenant
et d'ailleurs c'est cette remarque que
je ferai sur le débat de fond moi je ne
sais pas quelle institution quel
agencement quelle république 6e 7e ou 8e
ou dixième nous permettrait de faire
adopter par le Parlement et encore moins
par la population une réforme comme
celle que nous voyons mal justement sur
sur cette limite oui alors justement de
l'argent oui écoutez on va essayer de
vous départager si je puis dire
si le référendum ne peut pas être initié
par un président de la République
aujourd'hui on a ce référendum
d'initiative partagée qui apparaît comme
un ersatz politique de substitution ça
vous convaincre le premier gros saut
c'est à dire que puisqu'on arrive le
président ne veut pas s'exposer
c'est comme s'il y avait un transfert de
responsabilité vers
l'hypothèse de 5 millions ou quasiment
de d'électeurs il y a un problème
particulier de la France à l'égard du à
l'égard du référendum
c'est le référendum qu'un instauré la
République mais c'est aussi le
référendum qui a fait tomber la
République et donc la France a une
culture du référendum qui est plus
plébiscitaire et par conséquent il y a
une espèce de de recul de distance de
méfiance à l'égard de la pratique
référendaire on a vu en 1946 on l'a vu
en 2005 donc il y a une réserve à
l'égard de la pratique
référendaire et vous parlez du
référendum d'initiative partagée lorsque
vous discutez avec ceux qui l'ont établi
lors de la commission Balladur ils l'ont
organisé pour que ça ne marche jamais il
le disent il l'avoue c'est tellement
compliqué que c'est une sucette qui a
été donnée au peuple avec cette affaire
une concession montrer que on ouvrait
justement on élargissait le le champ du
référendum alors on l'a élargi comment
dire textuellement c'est à dire on a
permis que un référendum sur d'autres
questions que les questions
institutionnelles mais vous avez bien
dit référendum d'initiative partagée
c'est à dire à qui on donne la clé on
donne la clé au parlementaire parce que
ce qui l'ouvre par le il faut qu'il y en
a un cinquième ici et ceux qui peuvent
le fermer parce que même s'il y a les 4
millions 900 000 signatures ils peuvent
empêcher de référendum en examinant la
proposition donc initiative partagée
initiative parlementaire en réalité oui
mais là constitutionnellement il y a pas
un vice de forme c'est à dire que des
électeurs proposent quelque chose qui
peut être retoquée par l'Assemblée
nationale non mais là ce sont les
parlementaires
vous avez raison il a été construit pour
donner l'illusion et il y a rien de pire
que les institutions qui donnent des
illusions il faut que ce soit clair moi
je pense que dans la période où nous
sommes ça n'est pas vrai qu'en France
mais c'est vrai particulièrement en
France il y a un problème de capacité
pour le peuple de pouvoir se faire
entendre et que l'équilibre alors pour
le coup
représenter le peuple non mais attendez
l'équilibre des pouvoirs justement de ce
point de vue de la cinquième était
intéressant c'est qu'il y a la
représentation et par moment la
nécessité du référendum le peuple
souverain qui discute si on avait voté
le traité constitutionnel au Parlement
il aurait été mais massivement prouvé le
traité européen la Constitution
européenne massivement approuvé alors
qu'il a été fortement contestée par le
peuple français vous ne pouvez pas
durablement installer un système où sa
croix les différences de point de vue
pour ma part je pense que le champ
référendaire doit être repensé dans nos
institutions bien sûr l'initiative du
Président de la République je pense
qu'il faut ouvrir un champ référendaire
à l'initiative du Parlement lui-même qui
en sont simples sentir divisé pas pas
suffisamment conforté dans son point de
vue et doit pouvoir saisir le peuple et
l'initiative populaire ou citoyenne et
pas partager la vraie question c'est le
chant référendaire ou jusqu'où on
l'ouvre dans chacun des domaines par
exemple je ne trouverai pas ça qu'on
puisse ouvrir le champ référendaire sur
les droits fondamentaux oui mais qui en
déciderait
si vous décidez c'est la Constitution
c'est les sagesse le champ référendaire
ouvert à chacune
par exemple est-ce que l'immigration
ferait partie du champ référender
la question
ça ça fait partie des débats quand on
fait une nouvelle constitution sociale
pour ma part je pense que par exemple
quand ça s'attaque au droit fondamentaux
par exemple dire interdit d'avoir des
minarets ou enfin je sais pas des
minarets mais des mosquées en France par
exemple ça ça me paraîtrait pas pouvoir
être meilleur référendum parce qu'on
s'attaque au socle des droits
fondamentaux mais est-ce que vous
mettriez l'immigration dedans
personnellement j'ai pas une folle envie
d'avoir un débat sur l'immigration c'est
le peuple mais c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire d'un autre côté il y a rien
dans nos textes fondamentaux si ce n'est
le respect des droits de l'homme et le
droit d'asile qui doivent pas pouvoir
être contestés qui pourraient le mettre
en oeuvre donc
fermer à l'avance c'est là le problème
du du référendum je me souviens qu'en
1984 je crois le président Mitterrand
voulait ouvrir la page Facebook
référendum sur le référence avait été
retoqué par par le Sénat à l'époque
notamment mais moi je j'ai beaucoup de
réticences à l'égard du référendum et
d'une certaine manière ce que vous venez
de dire montre qu'il y a des réticences
c'est-à-dire on dit oui ok sur les
référendum mais pas sur tout tes
questions ou le peuple est souvent ou il
est pas souvent c'est à dire si on dit
que le peuple est souverain et à ce
moment-là on le laisse se prononcer sur
tout c'est-à-dire que le peuple se
prononcer pour référendum par référendum
est décidé de
par exemple sur la peine de mort un
référendum serait pas passé mais c'est
bien pour ça c'est bien pour ça que je
vous dis pas
c'est bien pour ça que que je vous dis
que la question du référendum est
peut-être comment dire un faux
instrument de la démocratie il y a un
vrai instrument populiste parce que
lorsque
c'est différent parce que il y a eu il y
a eu d'abord comment dire un vrai débat
il y a conduit au référendum moi je suis
conte et référendum sec or dans notre
dans notre société d'aujourd'hui avec
les réseaux sociaux avec avec les fake
news avec tout ce qu'on voit il me
semble difficile d'organiser un
référendum quel que soit le domaine avec
à partir d'un débat sérieux rationnel et
qui ne soit pas polluées
Pascale à votre avis sur cette question
du référendum
tel que la proposition vient d'être
énoncée par Madame linmann à savoir
qu'il émanerait pas du président de la
République mais qu'il émanerait du
Parlement par exemple la proposition
viendrait du Parlement est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer une double signature par
exemple sur la question du référendum et
est-ce que constitutionnellement ça peut
se faire bon très vite d'abord le
référendum d'initiative parlementaire
existe dans l'article 11 ça peut être
une proposition de Parlement mais je
vais essayer de faire une proposition
moi parce que je savais que Dominique
Rousseau n'était pas favorable au
référendum je connaissais ces positions
moi je suis beaucoup plus favorable
référendum donc on pourrait soit
effectivement adopter un vrai référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui a été
réclamée à corps et accrue par les
gilets jaunes souvenez-vous le
référendum administratif citoyennes
c'est bien quelque chose qui venait bien
là vraiment du peuple donc on peut on
pourrait faire un vrai référendum
initiative citoyenne comme en Italie par
exemple pour abroger une loi pour pour
adopter une loi avec 500 000 électeurs
ça une première possibilité deuxième
possibilité deuxième
électeur
sinon on peut également revoir ce fameux
référendum d'initiative partagé qui
d'ailleurs était avant le comité
baladure prévu dès le comité Vedène mais
à ce moment-là il faudrait je crois
raccourcir les délais c'est-à-dire ne
pas que ça dort pas 18 mois mais par
exemple beaucoup moins que on laisse je
crois un cinquième des parlementaires
mais qu'on abaisse précisément là aussi
peut-être à 500000 ou 1 million le
nombre de d'électeurs qui peuvent
soutenir la proposition et à ce
moment-là réduire les délais pas neuf
mois c'est beaucoup trop long il faut
laisser ça six mois et ensuite surtout
éviter ce qui est actuellement dans la
dans la Constitution c'est que si jamais
après le Parlement s'en empare il n'est
même pas obligé d'ailleurs se prononcer
vous rendez compte alors c'est fini on
en parle plus alors effectivement c'est
une usine à gaz mais je dirais même
cette c'est une tromperie c'est une
tromperie alors Dominique Regnier
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
puisque il y a pas de bon référendum et
moi je vous au fond je vous ai dit mon
sentiment principal je crois que
l'époque est au référendum par
l'évolution de la société est-ce qui a
été dit notamment sur sa politisation
conflictuelle par les réseaux sociaux
une espèce de de besoin que l'on sent
alors je ne sais pas exactement la
profondeur de ce besoin mais en tout cas
il est très visible très perceptible
dans une partie de la société politique
française c'est peut-être 4-5 millions
10 millions c'est pas 49 millions
d'électeurs mais c'est quand même
beaucoup donc il y a cette demande et de
l'autre côté je crois que soit les
questions qui seraient posées à
l'initiative du peuple en bas
embrasserait beaucoup de monde y compris
des personnes favorables au référendum
parce qu'on pourrait arriver sur des
sujets extrêmement délicats soit sur des
des grandes décisions à prendre qui
seraient difficile le peuple s'y
opposerait par référendum alors que ce
serait par hypothèse ce serait une
décision nécessaire il existe des
décisions nécessaires et il arrive que
ces décisions nécessaires soient
impopulaire allez-yonnements et prenons
l'exemple des retraites on peut dire que
on peut se fixer comme objectif que nous
comptes de retraite soit équilibrés ça
veut dire quand même j'espère que les
trois quarts où les 9 dixièmes des gens
pensent qu'il faut que le système de
retraite soit équilibré sauf que nous
faire croire qu'il y a qu'une seule
réforme possible bon je ne dis pas que
les autres se réfavora mais quand on dit
c'est défavorable c'est ça fait mal les
jambes mais ça fait mal acquis et
lesquels et comme on arbitre donc c'est
c’était dans le programme politique du
candidat on n'est pas en train de
débattre je veux dire que le référendum
lui-même il doit il peut très bien même
pour des décisions délicates être pris
parce que on aura trouvé des solutions
qui apparaîtront comme plus juste je
vais le dire ment on a 160 milliards de
déficit
[Musique]
c'est énorme il va sans doute falloir
prendre une série de décisions
objectivement nécessaire et je crois et
là sa populaire là je vois pas comment
on peut faire rentrer le référendum dans
un jeu pareil si vous voulez est-ce que
vous croyez que durablement on peut
multiplier les décisions populaires de
tout il va falloir commencer à le faire
c'est un peu l'idée oui Dominique si on
donne si on fait un référendum alors
vous allez dire que je suis embêtant en
tant que en tant que juriste mais
le peuple qui se prononce est-ce que
c'est le souverain ou est-ce que c'est
le Corps législatif parce qu'il y a
plusieurs peuples le peuple qui
s'exprime qui va voter une loi par
exemple sur les retraites ou sur
l'immigration sur la peine demeure
est-ce que c'est le peuple en tant que
souverain ou est-ce que c'est le peuple
en tant que législateur si c'est le
peuple en tant que législateur on peut
envisager l'hypothèse que le vote qui
sortirait du référendum pourrait être la
loi qui sortirait soumis au contrôle du
Conseil constitutionnel imaginez que le
peuple vote pour le rétablissement de la
peine de morts le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait censurer la loi
adoptée par le peuple parce qu'on ne
sait pas le souverain qui se serait
prononcé mais le Corps législatif dans
la personne du législateur donc il y a
deux peuples il y a le peuple souverain
et le peuple législateur et si en fait
en période de violence sociale il se
peut être que dans la question il se
comprend pas mais regardez
parce que une fois voté elle serait
anticonstitutionnel son amont du
référendum
des fois des pratiques
qui font jurisprudence prenons par
exemple la période de cohabitation à
l'époque du président Mitterrand vous
étiez ministre Marie-Noëlle Lindman le
domaine de la défense et de la politique
extérieure domaine réservé ça n'existe
nulle part dans la Constitution est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
parlementariser cette chose là qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez Olivier passeleck
parce que c'est une pratique finalement
j'allais dire
extraconstitutionnel et pourtant elle
tous les présidents ont l'ont adopté
après parce que c'était plus pratique
pour eux dans ma conception le
référendum c'est pas utilisé
quotidiennement
des vraies questions la réforme des
retraites on comprend pourquoi président
Macron n'a pas utilisé il savait que le
vote aurait été négatif il fallait bien
d'accord alors sinon ben écoutez oui moi
ce que je voulais dire simplement très
vite c'est que en fait non seulement la
Constitution est hybride mais le régime
de la Cinquième République était
géométrie variable et il montre qu'il
peut être beaucoup plus équilibré qu'il
n'est actuellement et c'est la période
dite de cohabitation c'est-à-dire que le
président se trouve confronté à une
majorité parlementaire qui lui est
opposée ça s'est produit à trois
reprises et là alors on retrouve
l'essence même de la Constitution et du
régime qui est par le menteur on c'est
un vrai régime parlementaire la
Cinquième République on n'a pas besoin
d'une révolution pour le rappeler 1
exécutive bicéphale oui droite
dissolution oui responsabilité du
Gouvernement devant le Parlement oui
donc cette bel et bien régime
parlementaire et on voit à ce moment-là
d'ailleurs ça plaît plutôt le pignon
l'opinion aime bien se rééquilibrage des
pouvoirs donc la cohabitation permet de
reparlementariser le régime et ça c'est
pas la Quatrième République non non
parce qu'on a le parlementarisme
rationalisé mais malheureusement là je
vais dire quelque chose de rime mais je
pense qu'on a plutôt assisté à
parlementarisme brutalisme vous êtes
d'accord avec ça Dominique régnait sur
ce sur retour au parlementarisme qui
s'exerce en période de cohabitation mais
pas en période de plein pouvoir
ni malheureusement dans une période où
la majorité relative et nous avons tous
honnêtement espéré que il y a un an que
nous allions faire une expérience
étonnante en France mais heureuse d'un
parlementarisme raisonnable construit
une question pour vous pour vous si on
regarde ce qui s'est passé dans notre
passé récent qu'il s'agisse de la CSG ou
même de la Constitution ça a été voté
sans majorité absolue et donc ça veut
dire que la Cinquième République et
assez souple pour permettre y compris
dans des périodes de cohabitation ou des
périodes où il n'y a pas de majorité de
faire fonctionner la politique oui mais
non justement moi je pense que une vraie
question c'est est-ce que le président
est-ce que le premier ministre procède
de la nomination du président où est-ce
qu'il est
issu du Parlement de d'un accord
majoritaire au Parlement parce que ça
change d'une certaine façon tout dans la
mesure où premièrement ça leur c'est sûr
que si le président il a la majorité à
100% pour faire il fait ce qu'il veut
l'horizon oh ça toute façon ils font ce
qu'ils veulent d'un côté comme de
l'autre
et donc mais par contre pourquoi je suis
pour que le Président le premier
ministre soit
issu du Parlement alors j'aime pas
toujours ce que font les Allemands mais
il y a un truc sur lequel je trouve
qu'ils ont plutôt raison c'est à dire en
début de mandat il y a un accord
majoritaire des composantes du Parlement
qui vont mettre en oeuvre des politiques
qui sont évidemment des compromis avec
s'il faut faire les réformes des
retraites alors oui on va ponctionner
les grosses entreprises ça vous voyez ce
que je veux dire il y a un compromis
global or nous faisons en permanence
l'économie de cela Dominique Rousseau
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
solution à l'allemande était possible
allemande était possible après la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron comment
aurait-il pu constituer cette
coalition quelque sorte majoritaire il
le révètent le RN d'un côté les insoumis
de l'autre
LR qui était sur une autre position
c'était introuvable non mais c'est ce
qu'a dit Dominique c'est-à-dire que il y
avait comme il y a la possibilité de
passer à un parlementarisme raisonnable
à un apprentissage du compromis de la
conciliation effectivement ce que font
les Allemands vous avez le SPD les
libéraux je crois et les écolos qui ont
mis
pas l'Assemblée nationale mais nous le
problème c'est que nous on a une
bonapartiste jacobine c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut que ce soit le le chef qui
détermine le programme et les autres se
mettent derrière sans concession le
problème des retraites le problème des
retraites c'est que le Président de la
République a voulu que sa réforme soit
celle du gouvernement s'il avait laissé
le gouvernement excusez-moi article 20
21 déterminer la politique du pays le
Premier ministre aurait pu discuter avec
les groupes parlementaires et trouver un
consensus sur une programme de ce qui
s'est passé non et il n'a pas un départ
qui va qui va passer débrouillez-vous et
la belle bonne pour la faire passer au
Parlement si on était dans un régime
parlementaire le président aurait laissé
la première Mini essayer de trouver un
compromis avec les différents groupes
sur la question de la réforme mais là on
a été bloqué parce que évidemment comme
ça venait du prénom ublique le LR ne
pouvait pas dire ok j'y vais le RN ne
pouvait pas etc etc donc on a eu un
parlementarisme on a une possibilité de
parlementarisme raisonnable bloqué par
le Président de la République
[Musique]
vous avez vu la citation d'Emmanuel
Macron je veux graver la liberté des
femmes de recourir à l'IVG dans la
Constitution alors il n'y a pas que
l'IVG on prête au président de la
République
différente modifications
qu'est-ce que vous pensez que sur la
réforme électorale par exemple moins de
parlementaires ça peut vous concerner au
Sénat ou à l'Assemblée nationale
l'institution de la proportionnelle
intégrale ou plus substantielle qu'elle
ne l'a été le vote obligatoire le
quinquennat deux questions à propos de
tous ces changements est-ce qu'il relève
de la Constitution qu'est-ce qui relève
d'une loi ordinaire et qu'est-ce qu'il
est opportun de faire et de raisonnable
qui veut commencer je peux tout de suite
répondre parce que je sais déjà de le
dire tout ce qui consomme le système
électoral pour les élections des députés
c'est la loi c'est la loi ordinaire
c'est même pas une organique pour le
système électoral le seul système
électoral qui est qui est dans la
Constitution c'est pour le président de
la République donc pour changer le mode
d'élection et député une loi ordinaire
suffit alors proportionnelle bon c'est
une question il faut qu'on en débatte
mais moi je pense que parmi toutes les
propositions si c'est pas l'occasion de
le redire d'ici là j'en ai une pour
aller justement dans le sens d'une
reparlementarisation ça a l'air de rien
c'est un petit peu aussi une bombe mais
ça a l'air de rien mais je pense qu'il
faut supprimer l'article 19 c'est à dire
désormais tous les pouvoirs du président
tous les pouvoirs du président sont
contre signés alors là sera un effet
très important parce qu'à ce moment
évidemment le pouvoir passe
progressivement de celui qui signe à
celui qui contre signe en laissant bien
sûr à ce moment là à son rôle principal
l'article 5 pour le président de la
République d'être un arbitre redevenir
en arbitre et comme l'a dit très
justement Dominique Rousseau qu'enfin
l'article 20 le Gouvernement détermine
et conduit la politique de la nation qui
est donc respecté en cohabitation
et bien le devienne la règle et que le
président reprenne de la hauteur et
cesse effectivement une sorte de
monarque absolue de droit je ne dirais
pas divin bien sûr mais droit
constitutionnel
on a étendu les choses donc deux
qu'est-ce qui opportun de faire et
est-ce qu'on peut
j'allais dire diluer le pouvoir
présidentiel en faisant contre signer
toutes les nominations par exemple
c'est une idée je pense très très riche
qui serait féconde mais je voulais
répondre à votre question que nous avons
vu à l'écran là la situation du
Président
je suis très inquiet de cette évolution
du rapport à la constitution
c'est-à-dire une évolution qui consiste
à
vouloir inscrire dans la loi
fondamentale des clients qui ont été
prises déjà qui ne sont absolument pas
menacés en France et au motif qui s'est
passé quelque chose ailleurs aux
États-Unis c'est que tout de même très
inquiétant et c'est d'autant plus
inquiétant que chaque président chaque
candidat même maintenant aura un objet
de révision à présenter dans son
programme cela devient l'objet politique
comme un autre alors évidemment
inutile d'imaginer ce que ça crée comme
précédent c'est-à-dire que rien
n'empêchera une personne élue plus tard
à l'Elysée de défaire ce que les autres
croyaient consolider en le faisant et je
terminerai en faisant une remarque on
dit la cinquième elle marche pas
toujours etc mais combien de révisions
l'ont abîmé
combien de décisions ont été prises sans
en mesurer réellement les conséquences
possibles je pense au quinquennat je
pense à l'inversion du calendrier
électoral ça a déjà été cité je pense
aussi à l'impossibilité de faire un
troisième mandat consécutif c'est une
vraie question après tout le peuple peut
en décider
là aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué pour
un président on le savait on n'est pas
surpris mais c'est très compliqué de
gouverner quand nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de se représenter j'imagine
c'est vraiment
absolument déménable et donc nous avons
fait beaucoup de révisions qui étaient
moi je les ai vécu comme ça en tout cas
présentez souvent comme dans l'air du
temps quelque chose qui devait s'imposer
par le rythme du monde du moment et à la
fin on a des résultats qui sont
catastrophiques et là on est en train
d'en faire l'expérience amer tout ce qui
nous aurait été bien utile comme pouvoir
par exemple la cohabitation si elle est
vertueuse et l'opinion en effet la
prouve ça n'est pas ça pourrait se
produire s'il y avait une dissolution
mais sinon ça ne se produit pas on y
était pas loin on n'est pas là on était
pas loin on fait il n'y a pas de
majorité même de loin relatives
le premier groupe après après si on veut
globaliser après Macron c'est 150
députés de gauche la nuit pêche pas une
majorité donc on est impuissant mais non
plus la réélection est impossible
président chaque jour est plus faible
donc nous créons nous-mêmes le
dysfonctionnement d'une cinquième qui
après nous voulons remplacer parce que
Marie-Noëlle je vais vous donner la
parole mais je vais vous provoquer un
petit peu finalement ce que ce que
propose les insoumis aujourd'hui je sais
que vous ne faites pas partie des
insoumis mais vous n'êtes pas éloigné
disons vous êtes à gauche de la gauche
ah oui je suis à gauche voilà vraiment à
gauche et c'est pas un reproche que je
vous fais là mais est-ce que finalement
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en disant les
décisions de l'exécutif sont pas les
décisions du peuple est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de revenir à ce que disait
en s'entendrait Daniel vous avez juste à
tort vous avez dit
républicaine moi je suis fait partie de
la gauche républicaine vieille tradition
jorcienne je crois aux institutions donc
vous voulez changer est-ce que vous vous
distinguez aujourd'hui des
revendications des insoumis ça dépend et
parce que votre voix porte vous êtes
considéré comme étant à la gauche de
redéfinir le champ référendaire
personnellement je pense qu'il faut
élargir le champ et faire et pour couper
court à l'idée qu'on n'a pas le temps de
discuter qu'on vote sans avoir très
beaucoup travaillé je trouve qu'on
pourrait prendre au moins exemple sur la
Suisse sur l'idée de la journée
référendaire c'est-à-dire qu'on sait à
l'avance qu'il y a une journée où on
fait les référendums et que à ce moment
là il y a une préparation du débat
politique pour que ce soit pas l'air du
temps à l'instant T etc pour ça premier
point deuxièmement moi je crois que le
Parlement je crois beaucoup Parlement je
suis totalement contre les mandares
vocatoires et système la révocation
c'est l'élection je suis pour qu'on
renforce le Parlement et de ce point de
vue je l'ai dit je pense que la façon
dont le premier ministre est choisi
c'est-à-dire par le vote du Parlement et
pas par la désignation du président me
paraît essentiel je suis aussi pour
limiter le champ de l'intervention du
président qui doit garder une partie de
recours et une partie de
grand arbitre et même pour être franche
d'une certaine présence à l'étranger je
pense que c'est quand même assez bien
accepté par les français même si quand
même je suis effondré de la faiblesse
des débats politiques actuels au sein du
Parlement sur la politique étrangère de
la France alors qu'il y aurait beaucoup
sur le budget il y aurait beaucoup donc
le troisième chose que je crois très
important c'est que
on peut pas faire des révisions
constitutionnelles tous les quarts
d'heure il y a des moments de temps
politique où il faut se reposer des
questions sur des choses sur par exemple
les droits fondamentaux inscrits dans la
Constitution et de ce point de vue je
trouve que la question de l'IVG c'est
pas seulement une question d'opportunité
parce qu'il y a des risques je pense
qu'à toute une série de droits qui ne
sont plus insuffisamment inscrits dans
la Constitution comme des garanties
durables et je prends un exemple qui
n'est même pas d'actualité aux yeux des
gens c'est le droit au logement
vous avez dans la Constitution le droit
à la propriété le droit au logement est
considéré comme deux valeurs
constitutionnelles mais quand il y a un
arbitrage à faire en train droit
constitutionnel et un droit
et notamment quand il s'agit d'exproprié
quand il s'agit de de comment dire
réquisitionner des choses comme ça mais
je peux vous assurer dans toute une
série de jugements au jour le jour
s'apaise donc il y a des moments faut se
dire quels sont les droits
constitutionnels par exemple la garantie
de ces données personnelles voyez il y a
peut-être un travail et là il faut un
travail de profondeur pendant quelques
années pour redéfinir le champ des
droits fondamentaux garanti par la
Constitution là par exemple sur les
données personnelles on pourrait
constitutionnaliser la protection des
données personnelles mais la puissance
publique même cette forme-là est
incapable de la faire respecter ce sont
des plateformes numériques américaines
vous avez des tas de droits
on fait quand même le rgpd ça c'est rien
du tout ça ne s'applique aux Européens
de savoir qu'est-ce que la nation a
décidé qui était ses missions
collectives de garantir des droits sur
le numérique par exemple parce que c'est
chinois et américain et ben il peut pas
il va douane il doit s'en donner les
moyens alors
sur ce toilettage qui est proposé oui
Olivier Patrick
pour dire que en réalité la réalité
juridiquement les droits fondamentaux
les libertés les plus essentielles ne
sont pas inscrites dans la Constitution
elle change ce qu'on appelle le blog de
compte dans le préambule donc finalement
ça n'ajoutera pas grand chose de
rajouter l'IVG bon c'est juste ça que je
voulais dire mais je pense que pour pour
comme on avance dans le débat je pense
qu'il faut que les téléspectateurs
soient conscients que tout ce qu'on dira
très peu de chance d'être approuvé dans
les dans les mois qui viennent mais
voilà ce sont des pistes pour l'avenir
oui Dominique Rousseau est-ce que vous
pensez vous pensez que il serait plus
juste et pour calmer un peu j'allais
dire la fronde populaire
de faire rentrer ses droits qui
les sociétés évoluent
l'IVG fait partie aujourd'hui d'une
évolution majeure comme d'autres
réformes sociétales et au regard du côté
pernicieux comme dirait l'économiste
Daniel Cohen du numérique est-ce que il
y a pas à toi l'été la Constitution pour
raffermir ses droits fondamentaux alors
toiletté
on l'a dit elle a été beaucoup toilettée
plus ou moins bien d'ailleurs toiletté
depuis
1958 on parle de la cinquième ou de la
Sixième République mais enfin en 58 le
président était élu pour ces temps
maintenant c'est 5 ans une fois
renouvelable il était élu par un corps
électoral maintenant par le suffrage
universel en 58 l'Assemblée nationale
siégé en deux sessions
de de six mois de trois mois maintenant
c'est à l'année il y avait pas de
conseils constitutionnel où il était
tout petit il y avait pas d'occuper
c'est il y avait pas de contre la priori
autrement dit on parle de la Cinquième
République mais le comment dire le cadre
constitutionnel a complètement changé
donc un toilettage supplémentaire
risquerait d'arriver à espèce de
bricolage institutionnel ce qui fait que
on ne sait plus exactement
ce que la Constitution nous dit de
nous-mêmes n'oubliez pas que la
Constitution c'est pas simplement un
texte technique qui répartit les
compétences entre président Premier
ministre Parlement par le Parlement la
Constitution c'est aussi comment dire ce
qui donne une identité à une société
c'est une sorte de miroir dans lequel on
se regarde carte d'identité voilà on dit
tiens j'étais le droit moi ce qui me
frappe ce qui m'intéresse évidemment ce
qui m'interroge parce que je le prends
aussi comme interrogation c'est que
tous les mouvements sociaux
un moment donné demande à ce que leur
revendication soit inscrite dans la
Constitution alors je suis content en
constitutionnaliste les gens qui
défilent dans la rue pour le respect de
la biodiversité il voudrait que ça deux
ça rentre dans la Constitution les
femmes faut que ça rentre dans la
Constitution donc moi je pourquoi les
mouvements pourquoi les mouvements
sociaux ont toujours un débouché
constitutionnel j'ai préféré qu'ils
aient un boucher un débouché
constitutionnel qu'un débouché violent
ça me paraît plus positif et en ce sens
la Constitution et ce qui donne son
identité c'est le texte dans lequel une
société se reconnaît et il y a une
phrase de Benjamin Constant moi qui qui
me comment dire qui anime ma réflexion
de constitutionnalisme
et qui disait de mémoire tant que les
idées et les institutions sont de niveau
les institutions subsistent mais quand
les idées et les institutions ne sont
plus au même niveau à ce moment-là
dit-il et je pense que pour terminer je
pense que nous sommes dans un moment où
les institutions ne sont plus au niveau
des au niveau des idées et que par
conséquent il faut modifier les
institutions pour les mettre au niveau
alors les idées Benjamin Constant on
pourrait dire l'esprit du siècle ou
l'esprit du moment et l'esprit du moment
fait que les citoyens la société acteurs
ou à raison la société demande à être
associée à la fabrication des lois c'est
ça vous n'avez pas d'institution il y a
une question aux citoyens des associés à
la fabrication qui fâche et à laquelle
peut-être je vais vous demander de
trancher etc
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on appelle la
société multiculturelle il y a un
délayage
par exemple en ce qui concerne la
violence régalienne est-ce qu'elle doit
être le monopole de la police parce que
cette chose là est contestée aujourd'hui
vous avez aujourd'hui dans le débat
politique français vous avez pas
aujourd'hui uneanimité pour considérer
que la violence régalienne parce que
c'est un effondrement de la culture
politique non mais vous considérez
Dominique ce qui est proposé par une
partie de la classe politique est un
effondrement démocratique c'est une
incompréhension fondamentale de ce
qu'est le pouvoir rattraper après je
vous laisserai mais c'est un
effondrement de la définition je dirais
alors les gens parfois pensent à Max
Weber Max Weber il est mort en 1920 et
bien les auteurs l'ont écrit avant lui
boudin et d'autres et bien avant encore
le pouvoir pour être souverain il faut
qu'il ait la maîtrise du de l'euro du
recours
la violence sinon il n'est pas le
pouvoir souverain si tu as un pouvoir
plus fort par la violence c'est là
qu'elle se trouve à l'état si vous
voulez et donc c'est une logique c'est
même pas une invention c'est un
mécanisme logique il est il est insensé
de dire que on pourrait avoir un système
dans lequel l'État n'aurait pas le
monopole de la violence légale
heureusement vous êtes pas d'accord
là-dessus Marie là-dessus mais la
question c'est est-ce que la violence
est proportionnée
parce que le débat actuellement je
n'entends pas beaucoup il y a des
annares des Black Blocs tout le bataclan
mais le gros de la population française
même quand elle conteste la police pour
une part d'entre elles c'est quand même
vieux comme Hérode en France on a on
n'aime pas spontanément la police et en
même temps on considère qu'on en a
impérativement besoin ce que ce que je
ressens n'est pas du tout la
contestation du de la violence légitime
de l'État quand il doit garantir la
sécurité et l'intérêt général
la vraie question c'est l'abusus c'est
jusqu'où on mesure
parce qu'il y a des règles justement la
violence doit être proportionnée il faut
faire peut-être qu'il y a des choses à
réfléchir sur faire la preuve qu'on a
fait de la prévention suffisante il y a
un débat politique la violence
proportionnelle une manifestants qui a
incendie des policiers par exemple c'est
une question que je pose là moi je sais
pourquoi effectivement il trouve les
moyens de le
sacrément parce que si on vous met le
feu vous avez il y a d'autres pays qui
sont aujourd'hui à confronter au même
sujet qui ont des stratégies de
distanciation des stratégies policières
différentes ce débat est légitime moins
compréhensif à l'égard de la vie moi je
veux bien que tout soit de la faute de
la gauche qu'il y a encore
oui toute façon on est historiquement en
France un rapport à la violence qui est
quand même assez étrange c'est
Olivier
que il faut
simplement c'est vrai que la France
insoumise remet en cause cette violence
cette semaine a pas la violence légitime
sa majeur ah si si et Mélenchon avec des
comptes on sait très bien que lui il a
eu des mailles appartient avec la police
on voit bien que vraiment il veut
s'opposer de toute façon à la police et
d'où les slogans tout le monde déteste
la police etc
la mauvaise République
faut aussi relativiser tout ça même si
personnellement je suis pas du tout dans
ce genre là non ce que je veux dire par
là c'est qu'on met 68 CRSS euh 10
personnes même la police je l'ai entendu
est-ce que pour autant la société
française est devenue plus Antipolis
qu'elle ne l'était avant voilà donc non
non c'est pas la question
de la police et de l'État et de la
justice de garantir
Rousseau vous êtes pas exprimé sur cette
violence je me suis pas exprimé parce
que je pense que ce qui a été dit me
paraît me paraît juste c'est-à-dire
c'est normal que l'État est le monopole
de la violence légale légitime et c'est
également normal que l'État fasse un
usage proportionné de la violence je
veux dire que voulez-vous dire d'autre
c'est de bon sens même et il suffit de
comment dire à la fois que le ministre
de l'Intérieur il suffit aussi il faut
aussi que le Parlement joue son rôle
dans dans le contrôle éventuellement des
abus fait par la discussion sur la
stratégie policière la police donc les
les deux pour moi oui l'État doit avoir
elle doit continuer à avoir le monopole
de la violence légitime mais en
contrepartie il faut qu'il en fasse un
usage proportionné voilà que voulez-vous
le dire d'autre écoutez on va essayer
quand même de terminer sur une note un
peu plus un peu plus positif
sur les réformes il y en a peut-être une
ou deux où il y a un consensus pourquoi
on peut pas avancer dans ce domaine là
je pense par exemple pour cumule des
mandats on entend de tout bord à droite
et à gauche considérer qu'il faudrait
rétablir le cumul des mandats deuxième
chose sur l'inversion du calendrier des
élections entre législatives et
présidentielle là aussi il y a il
semblerait qu'il y ait une volonté d'un
côté comme de l'autre de bouger
qu'est-ce qui faisable et qu'est-ce qui
n'est pas faisable et qu'est-ce qui
serait opportun aujourd'hui d'avancer
pour faire unité nationale alors vous
avez être deux minutes chacun et ça
permet de conclure notre émission
je reste partisan du non cumul des
mandats dans la mesure où un
parlementaire ne représente pas sa
circonscription il représente la nation
et que par conséquent un parlementaire
doit pas un parlementaire élu à
Marseille ne doit pas ne doit pas
défendre les intérêts de Marseille il
doit défendre les intérêts de la nation
et il faut qu'il y ait une séparation
entre ceux qui ont à gérer les affaires
locales ou régionales et ceux qui ont à
gérer les affaires nationales une des
raisons du déclin du Parlement tient
précisément en fait que les
parlementaires sont tellement imprégnés
par le souci de défendre les intérêts
locaux de leur circonscription qu'ils
oublient l'intérêt national donc de ce
côté là moi je pense que on doit
continuer et sur l'inversion de
calendrier mais ça si vous voulez c'est
de c'est de la chiquenaude c'est-à-dire
que le vous pouvez pas traiter la
question de l'inversion du calendrier
électoral sans présenter la question 1
de la durée du mandat de de des pouvoirs
la durée du mandat un mandat 7 ans ou
deux moi je considère si vous voulez que
la durée du mandat importe peu dans tous
les pays où le président est élu par le
peuple je dis bien été lui par le peuple
je n'ai pas le président qui dirige mais
le Premier ministre par conséquent par
conséquent il y a pas un lien mécanique
entre élection populaire et hyper
présidentialisation moi ce qui manque il
faut les distinguer donc il faut les
distinguer et une des si vous demandez
une une réforme est-ce que je proposerai
c'est que le prénom République ne
préside plus le Conseil des ministres
que le Conseil des Ministres se tiennent
désormais à Matignon sous la présidence
du Premier ministre et on retrouverait
ainsi le président dans une position
d'arbitre merci Olivier passelette
brièvement sur ces deux sujets un petit
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure
évidemment une vraie une vraie une vraie
réforme mais révolutionnaire serait de
supprimer les pouvoirs propres du
présent de la République car tous les
autres pouvoirs même ceux dit du domaine
réservé diplomatie et défense sont des
pouvoirs contre signés c'est la pratique
qui a fait que le président a finalement
à dominé les institutions mais c'est pas
dans la Constitution la Constitution
peut avoir une application une pratique
totalement parlementaire et équivalente
et je suis heureux de l'avoir entendu à
d'autres pays d'Europe où le président
de la République est élu au suffrage du
Mercat direct mais où il n'a pas cette
espèce de inexeste pas c'est je répète
cette monarchie absolue de droit mère
droit
sur l'idée que l'important c'est de
redonner un premier ministre un
parlement qui est réellement le pouvoir
je donne je vais parler d'un sujet qui
peut évoquer
voilà je vais vous expliquer tout le
monde se plaint en France que la loi
c'est de la bureaucratie l'État c'est
bureaucratisé la nature de la loi et du
Règlement tel qu'il est défini dans nos
traditions législatives
bureaucratise l'État est par ailleurs
rend difficile la prise en compte du
réel sur les différents territoires et
pousse à l'idée que la loi doit
s'adapter au territoire moi je pense que
c'est une grave menace la loi doit
rester unique dans notre République mais
faut que la loi soit plus structurée en
laissant davantage de marge de manœuvre
que le réglementaire aujourd'hui corset
merci Marie-Noël line mal je sais pas si
vous avez été influencé par la personne
qui est en face de vous qui s'appelle
Anna arrête qu'ils aient le que dans une
société quand la loi ce bureaucratise en
bureau basé à danger pour la démocratie
sur les deux points on termine là-dessus
rapidement avec des remarques de de
politologue à l'adresse de mes collègues
publicistes ce qu'ils savent très bien
et vous savez aussi la triste quand on
touche une institution il faut même si
c'est apparemment un détail les effets
systémiques sont souvent impressionnants
je donne deux exemples un premier
exemple on peut revenir au cumul des
mandats si on veut rapprocher par
exemple par hypothèse les députés des
besoins plus locaux du peuple si on ne
fait pas parce qu'on dit que c'est pas
nécessaire il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on fait avec le mode de scrutin parce
que la proportionnel dont on parle
souvent parce que tu as de liste elle
éloigne beaucoup etc c'est une première
remarque ma deuxième remarque elle est
sur ce qui a été évoquée par mes
collègues que je trouve très intéressant
sur ces réformes qui changeraient le
pouvoir du président et vous étiez
d'accord même la sénatrice avec l'esprit
de ces propositions ça aurait davantage
énorme je trouve c'est que c'est à
sélectionnerait peut-être d'autres
profils pour l'élection présidentielle
je pense ce serait très très
utile au pays que nous ayons des profils
vous voyez au fond ceux qui ne se sont
jamais présentés qui n'y sont pas
arrivés c'était parfois des profils très
différents de ceux qui sont arrivés je
vais penser à Rocard à Balladur à Delore
à barre c'est très intéressant de voir
que ce sont pas les mêmes profils et
c'est peut-être pas une bonne chose que
nous un système qui promettant au fond
la royauté sélectionne des psychologies
et des profils qui sont pas ceux avec
lesquels on peut faire le plus
facilement comprendre on va terminer
là-dessus et
voilà merci de votre avis merci Madame
merci Madame merci merci Madame merci
Monsieur écoutez il me reste à vous
présenter une brève bibliographie alors
je rappelle Olivier passeleck vous avez
publié avec Francis Hamon un ouvrage sur
le référendum en Europe bilan et
perspective depuis vous n'avez pas
changé d'idées non
Dominique Rousseau sites pour la
démocratie continue sur DJ Jacob c'est
quoi cette démocratie continue en deux
mots tout simplement c'est une
démocratie qui ne s'arrête pas entre
deux moments électoraux donc elle est
continue et qui ne s'arrête pas comment
disait autrefois qu'il ne s'arrête pas
aux portes de l'entreprise qui ne
s'arrête pas aux portes de la famille
mais c'est une démocratie dont le
principe se diffuse dans l'ensemble de
la société et ne reste pas simplement au
niveau de l'État
Marie-Noëlle vous avez publié il y a
quelques années merci pour ce changement
il s'agissait de quoi vous êtes sur
beaucoup de choses en général je plaide
pour ce changement institutionnel car
quand je regarde l'exercice de la gauche
au pouvoir même avec un par exemple sous
Jospin qui était pas Président je vois
les fragilités structurelles du fait
qu'il n'y ait pas besoin d'un accord
parlementaire entre l'ensemble des
forces de la majorité et qu'on soit
ballottées en fonction des événements
sans qu'il y ait un accord politique
d'ensemble qui trouve son équilibre et à
un moment ou un autre les forces le
peuple se décrochent de des forces
politiques et il y a toujours des crises
on finit toujours des fins de mandat
quel qu'il soit dans des mauvaises
situations merci alors Domi Régnier je
rappelle que la fondation la Paul vous
publiez de nombreuses études sur tous
les sujets politiques et que vous même
vous avez coordonné l'ouvrage le 21e
siècle du christianisme
je n'ai pas changé d'avis et vous avez
pas voilà mais vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis je vois écoutez il me reste à
vous remercier d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci à l'équipe d'elcp et
avant de nous quitter je vous soumet
cette citation si l'on se lance dans un
mécano bavard et déclammatoire décrochés
des réalités historiques
le retour à la cinquième à la pardon à
la Quatrième République deviendra
effectif et irrémédiable voilà c'est une
citation d'Arnaud Tessier
[Musique]